The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK.
So this is a fun lecture.
This is the lecture
where understanding
the gradient, which
we did last time;
the divergence, that
we almost completed;
those two pieces
now come together
into Laplace's equation.
Things work in a fantastic
way, so I enjoy this one.
So the result will be that we
have the potential function
u that we've spoken about,
and take its gradient.
Now is coming a stream
function, s, that's
connected with the divergence.
When the divergence
is zero, there's
something called a
stream function, s.
And these, the connections
between those two functions, u
and s, are crucial.
And connecting
gradient to divergence
will take us to
Laplace's equation.
And then you'll see the special,
special role of x+iy in 2-D.
So this is in two dimensions.
OK.
So let me begin with divergence.
This is the divergence
of w, of course.
And solve it.
Just as we wanted to solve
Kirchhoff's current law,
A transpose w equal zero, so
now in the continuous case,
we want to find solutions to --
we want to find divergence-free
fields.
Source-free fields,
you could say.
That's about the
best word we have,
divergence-free, meaning
there is no divergence.
So what have we got here?
We've got one equation
in two unknowns.
Last time, with the
gradient business,
we had two equations for u,
and only that one unknown.
Now we've got one equation,
two unknowns, because we're
looking at the transpose.
So there should be
a lot of solutions.
Right?
If you give me a
w_1, then probably
I'll be able to find a w_2.
But there's a neat way
to describe the solutions
to that equation, the
divergence-free fields.
It's to introduce something
called a source function --
a stream function,
sorry, stream function.
OK, and now the idea will be
that if I let -- let me try.
I take any function s(x,y),
any function whatever.
So now I try --
let w_1 be ds/dy.
Maybe I should say, maybe
I should go this way.
I'm looking for solutions.
OK.
So I take any function s, I
take its y derivative to be w_1.
And you can tell me
what w_2 has to be?
So if w_1 is ds/dy,
this will be what?
This'll be the second -- the x
derivative of the y derivative.
Right?
If w_1 is the y derivative, then
when I take the x derivative,
I've got this cross derivative.
So what would be the
smart choice for w_2?
So I'll say then,
then w_2 will be --
now I've sort of
said what w_1 is,
what's the w_2
that goes with it?
Well, it's whatever it
takes to cancel this.
I want this to be, in other
words I want it to get zero,
so this should be the
second derivative s.
And what am I going
to put now? dydx.
I'm using the same
very crucial fact
that the cross derivative
can be in either order.
So what do I see for w_2?
Do you see what w_2 is?
This is supposed to match that.
There's a minus
sign. w_2 is what?
Minus ds/dx.
Right?
That's the minus ds/dx.
If I take any function s, I
let w_1 be its y derivative
and w_2 be minus
its x derivative,
then the divergence
will be zero.
Because I'll have
the cross derivative
minus the cross derivative,
of course that'll be zero.
So these will be my w_1's -- my
w's. w_1, w_2, coming from s.
So I have what I expect,
with two unknowns,
only one equation, I've
got lots of solutions.
I create any function
s, and that will be one.
So that's a stream function.
And it has a physical
meaning, so we get to see it.
And it has a fantastic
connection to the potential.
So up to now -- so this is
now the moment pieces come
together.
Up to now, we had the divergence
and the gradient separately.
So up to now, what we had was,
we started with the potential
u, and we went to v -- I called
it v for this application --
[du/dx, du/dy].
OK.
And now, over on this side,
I had the divergence of w
equals zero.
And that led me to w being,
what we just said, ds/dy,
and minus ds/dx.
OK, two separate pictures.
Now we're going to
connect the framework,
going to give the
connection between v and w.
And the connection will
be the easiest possible;
they'll be equal.
So the c in our framework
is the identity.
I want to say, I want
to look at our framework
when c is the identity.
So v and w are the same.
In other words, what
equation do we get then?
We started with u,
we take the gradient
of u, that's v. We go
over here, and we still
have the gradient of u,
because this was the v
and now it's also the w.
And then we take
-- what do we take?
Minus the divergence of
the gradient of u, equals,
let's say, f.
Shall we say f, to
make something happen?
Or zero -- I'll say zero.
I'll say zero.
Yeah, because zero
is the one that
give us Laplace's equation.
The official name would be
-- that's Laplace's equation.
Do you recognize it?
We'd better write
it out properly.
The divergence of the
gradient is the Laplacian.
So this is Laplace.
Famous equation.
Steady-state type of equation.
It goes with
steady-state problems.
Let's just figure
out what this is.
So w is, since these are the
same, w is now [du/dx, du/dy].
It's the gradient.
Now what happens,
do you see what
happens when I take the
divergence of the gradient,
the divergence of this w?
I just want to write
that equation out.
It's crucial.
I need brilliant colors
and lights shining, now,
for what goes in there.
Because I want to take the
divergence of the gradient.
So what does that mean?
I take the x derivative
of the first component,
plus the y derivative
of the second component.
The minus sign is not going
to matter, with a zero
on the right hand side.
I could cancel the minus.
So, but let me say it again.
The divergence is, it applies
to a vector, I've got a vector.
I take the x component
of the first -- of w_1.
So that'll give me d
second u/dx squared.
And I take the y derivative --
I should have said derivative --
y derivative of the
second component.
And the y derivative of that
is d second u/dy squared.
And I get zero.
So that's Laplace's equation.
You see, the whole idea
is Laplace's equation,
in working with
Laplace's equation,
we have three elements, here.
The gradient comes in,
the divergence comes in,
and equality comes in.
Would you like to see a more
general Laplace's equation?
Well, a more general
Poisson's equation.
So underneath Laplace,
let me write Poisson.
You got the pronunciation, the
brilliant French pronunciation
there, of Poisson?
That was my best.
I can't improve on that one.
So it comes in when
there's a right-hand side.
So the normal Poisson equation
is second derivative with
respect to x, second derivative
with respect to y -- well,
actually, it should
have a minus there.
Really should be a minus there.
You remember why
the minus is there.
The minus is there to make
the whole thing positive.
Right?
That sounds crazy, that the
minus makes it positive.
But these second derivatives are
negative definite, as always,
and the minus makes
them positive definite.
So I don't remember whether --
maybe I often include the minus
over here -- equal f(x,y).
So there's a source.
Poisson has a source term.
Laplace doesn't.
And just while I'm talking
about this framework,
if there was a c(x,y),
so this would be or.
I'll put or.
The more general one
would be the x derivative,
because I'm taking the
divergence, of a c(x,y)du/dx,
and the y derivative of a c
-- so you see the difference.
I'm now allowing some
variable conductivity.
Variable whatever,
variable material.
du/dy equals f, again.
So that would be the
more general one.
I don't think we
plan to study that.
Well, that's not
the most general,
I could have more and
more things there.
But that shows you
a variable material.
Yeah, that material is variable.
I would use the word --
what word would I use?
It doesn't depend
on the direction.
I'm using the same c(x,y)
in the x direction and the y
direction.
Therefore in all directions.
And I didn't come
prepared with that word.
What's the word
for when it doesn't
depend on the direction?
Isotropic!
Thanks.
Isotropic.
So that's isotropic.
So that's really
our framework there.
At least for
isotropic materials.
And then we could
have more general
with anisotropic materials.
That would be fun.
All of those things are fun.
But Laplace's equation
is the most fun of all.
So let me take f to
be zero, c to be one,
get back up to
Laplace's equation,
and begin to make connections.
Begin to make connections.
OK.
The beautiful connection
is the one right here.
When v and u are the same,
when v and w are the same,
then I just read off.
If v is the same as w, then
how is the potential function,
which is on the left side,
connected to the strain
function, which is coming
from, any time div w is zero,
I've got a stream
function in 2-D, here.
The connection is
just, those two match.
du/dx is the same
as ds/dy, and du/dy
is the same as minus ds/dx.
You see that the two sides of
our world are coming together.
We're dealing with flows
that are both gradient flows,
they come from a
potential, you could often
say potential flows, I see the
word ideal flows coming in.
These are very special flows.
So aero couldn't work entirely
with these flows, of course.
These are such ideal flows.
Proper aerodynamics,
you've got shocks,
you've got all sorts
of stuff going on.
But in a region where
everything's beautiful,
then you get back to this,
total steady state, steady flow,
steady potential flow.
We've got those
equations that connect u
on one side with the
divergence business,
the stream function
on the other side.
So I want to focus on these.
Actually, I mean, so the
heart of Laplace's equation
is in there.
OK.
First, do you know the
names of those two guys?
I shouldn't call
them guys, they're
the greatest
mathematicians ever.
Maybe after Gauss.
Do you know whose names are
associated with those two
equations?
Well, Lagrange was great.
I'm not saying anything
about Lagrange.
But he didn't do this.
So two, one French
and one German.
So the French guy's
name is Cauchy.
And the German is --
so these are Cauchy,
and the German is a
really fantastic guy.
Anybody know his name?
Cauchy-Riemann.
Yeah.
The other name is Riemann.
Cauchy-Riemann equations,
that connect the two pieces,
u and s.
And they're the subject
of an enormous theory
that we'll just touch on here.
OK.
And we'll see them graphically,
and we'll find solutions.
So this is one way
to pose our problem.
Notice something here.
I think that if we
have these equations,
a solution u should
satisfy Laplace's equation.
Because this equality will
take us around the loop.
So do you see that if I
could solve these two --
here's the point.
I'm going to get Laplace's
equation solved by u.
Laplace's equation will
also be solved by s.
The stream function.
So what's going to happen
is, I get two solutions.
A pair of solutions.
Laplace's equation, solutions
to that come in pairs, u and s.
So we get them two at a time.
And they're connected
in this remarkable way.
Let's see, can you see
that u will satisfy --
this is the key to everything.
Does u satisfy
Laplace's equation?
Sure.
I take the x derivative
of that, and I add
to the y derivative of that.
Do you see, it works.
The x derivative of this,
plus the y derivative of this
is exactly the cancellation
of the cross that I wanted.
So I do these, I combine
those into Laplace.
Shall I just go through
that verbally again?
I take the x derivative
of this, which gives me
the cross derivative of s.
This asked me to take
the y derivative,
so I get the cross
derivative again.
With the minus sign,
they add to zero.
I just want to point
out that also, s
satisfies Laplace's equation.
Can we do that one?
I claim that also,
the stream function
solves Laplace's equation.
Because we want the x
derivative of ds/dx.
So ds/dx is minus this.
Do you see what's happening?
When I take the x
derivative of ds/dx,
I get minus the cross
derivative of u for this guy.
It's the y derivative
of this, which is
plus the cross derivative of u.
They cancel.
So u and s are just together.
Oh, let's find some solutions.
They're great to find.
And then draw them.
OK, can I find some solutions
to Laplace's equation.
And I'm going to
find them in pairs.
So I'm going to have a list
of u's and their corresponding
s's.
OK.
These are solutions to Laplace.
These are, solve
Laplace's equation.
So we've got Laplace's
equation in our minds.
Actually, furthermore,
they solve Cauchy-Riemann.
Because they're
going to be connected
by our Cauchy-Riemann equation.
So, solve Laplace
and Cauchy-Riemann.
OK.
Suppose I take u(x,y)=x.
I'm going to start
with an easy solution.
That certainly solves
Laplace's equation.
You've got Laplace's
equation in mind?
Let me write it up here again.
u_xx+u_yy=0.
I take the chance
to write it again,
to do it in this little
bit shorter notation,
just subscripts
instead of partials.
And also, s_xx+s_yy=0.
But most of all,
the Cauchy-Riemann
that connects the two.
Well, does u=x solve
Laplace's equation?
Of course it does.
The second x derivative, if
the function is x, is zero.
And the second y derivative
is very, very zero.
[LAUGHTER] So what's s?
What's the s that goes with it?
It'll be simple, too.
So the s -- so u is x, right?
I'm starting with this x.
So du/dx is one.
So what do you figure s is?
If du/dx -- see, u is just x
itself, so du/dx is only a one.
That derivative was easy.
Then ds/dy is
supposed to be one,
and ds/dx is supposed
to be zero, I guess.
Do you see what s is? y.
S is y. s is y.
Of course, that solves
Laplace's equation, too,
and it solves Cauchy-Riemann.
The x derivative of this is
the y derivative of that.
One equal one.
And the y derivative of that
is minus the x derivative
of that, zero equal zero.
OK, so that's an easy one.
I'm going to go up a level.
I want to take a second degree.
So my next guy in the
list will be -- a pair,
it's a list of pairs -- will
be x squared minus y squared.
First of all, it better
not be in that list
unless it solves
Laplace's equation.
And then if it is,
we'll find an s.
So plug it in mentally,
can you plug this
into Laplace's equation?
What's the second x
derivative of this function?
Two.
Right? xx brings down a two.
What's the second y derivative?
Minus two, from this term.
And then put them into Laplace's
equation, two minus two.
Correct.
Zero.
All right.
Now I'm looking for the
s that goes with it.
The other one in the pair.
OK, maybe I'd better
think through what --
so this is supposed to
give me the s, du/dx --
let me copy Cauchy-Riemann here,
so we can just focus entirely
on that board.
So du/dx, this is 2x in my
example. du/dy is minus 2y.
So what am I learning?
ds/dy should be 2x.
ds/dx should be 2y.
There are minus
signs on both there.
What's s?
Do you see s?
The y derivative is 2x,
the x derivative is 2y,
and that stream function is 2xy.
Right?
2xy.
Because the x derivative
of this is 2y,
and the y derivative
of this is 2x.
And we saw 2xy last time also.
And of course, it solves
Laplace's equation easily.
Plug that in, the second
derivative is zero.
The second x derivative is
zero, second y derivative
is zero, everything.
So that's a pair.
This is a nice pair.
You want to shoot
for third degree?
We could maybe figure out third
degree, just by jiggling it.
After that, we're
going to need an idea
to get up to fourth degree.
Let me try third degree.
Cubics, now.
So I'm looking -- first I just
want to get somebody here.
So it's some x cubed.
And then I'm going to need some
more stuff, because x cubed
by itself certainly won't work.
I need something more.
And I want to plug it
into Laplace's equation
and figure out
what should it be?
OK, so when I plug this
into Laplace's equation,
what do I get?
Let me do Laplace's
equation over here,
to try to get the
u of degree three.
So what's u_xx, so far?
6x, right?
Bring down, we've got 3x
squared, then we get 6x,
so I've got a 6x.
And I'm looking for -- so u_yy
should be minus 6x to cancel
that.
So what do I want there?
What do I need?
I need a minus,
I'm sure of that.
So the second y derivative
should be this 6x deal.
What do I want?
3xy squared?
That sounds good.
Let me write it down
and see if it is good.
OK.
The second y derivative.
Yes.
We'll bring down a two, and
then the y's will disappear
and I'll have the minus 6x.
Golden.
OK, that's great.
That's great.
Is that correct?
I mean, it's great,
but is it right?
Yes.
OK.
Now, you have faith that
there's another one?
Well, yeah, there
is another one.
Cauchy-Riemann
never let us down.
There will be an s
that'll go with that,
that'll solve a
Cauchy-Riemann equation,
and it'll look like it.
And I think, I think -- and I
just sort of reverse x and y
to get another one, because
if I exchange x and y,
I'm still OK with
Laplace's equation.
I think something like
3yx squared minus y cubed.
If that worked, then this
one should work, too.
Because I just switched
x and y, and I think
it'll work right here.
The second x
derivative will be 6y,
and the second y derivative
will be minus 6y.
I think that's good.
OK.
Let's put this list
on hold for a moment.
Something's -- obviously,
there's some pattern here that
we've got to locate.
Can I put it on
hold for a moment
and take, for example,
the graph of this one.
And I want to draw the pictures.
Before I get a
complete list, I want
to draw the pictures
of these functions.
And what do I mean by pictures?
I mean draw the -- so now I'm
taking the u to be x squared
minus y squared,
and the s to be 2xy.
And I want to draw those, I
want to draw the vector field
of the gradients of those guys.
OK, so this is the u
-- I want to draw --
this is the potential x
squared minus y squared.
So what are they
equipotential curves?
So this is now --
I'm drawing the flow.
And to draw the flow, I draw the
curves on which the potential
is a constant. x squared minus
y squared equal constant.
So what kind of a
curve is x squared
minus y squared equal constant?
It's a hyperbola.
So x squared minus y squared
equal, let's take one,
for example.
As one constant.
So x=1 will be on the
curve, when y is zero.
And then what else
will be on the curve?
If x is a little bigger,
like two -- so here's (1, 0).
That point is certainly -- x
squared minus y squared is one
for that.
Suppose I go out to x=2.
What should y be then,
to make this right?
Where's the curve going?
When x is two, what is y?
Square root of
three, plus or minus.
So square root of three
is something like this,
up or down.
It's a curve, like so.
It's a hyperbola.
And now, if I change
c to four, let's say,
then it'll go through (2,
0), and it'll go up this way.
And if I change x to something
very small, it'll still -- oh,
there's a Greek
word, asymptotes.
Oh, yeah.
What do I get if -- the
asymptote is when this is zero.
Yeah.
When that is zero,
what's my curve?
What are x and y?
They'll be the same. x
will be y, or minus y.
I'll be on that straight line,
or on this straight line.
So all these other
hyperbolas are
kind of asymptotic,
whatever the word is.
Right, do you see them?
As a bunch of hyperbolas?
And actually, more
hyperbolas -- well, yeah.
Let's see, back when
I had a one there,
I took x and y to be positive,
and I got that hyperbola.
But since I'm
squaring them there,
also these hyperbolas are here.
So these same guys are on
that side of the picture.
Those are the equipotentials.
So these are the equipotentials.
OK.
Now, let me draw s.
So those will be the equi -- no,
I don't want to say equi-stream
functions.
That's awkward.
So now, I want to draw s equal
constant, like one or whatever.
So I've drawn this with
a whole lot of constants,
and now I want to
draw the other guys.
What do those curves look like?
And what's their name?
A curve on which the stream
function is a constant
has a nice name, streamline.
So now I'm going to
draw the streamlines.
And what are the streamlines?
The streamlines
will be the curves
that the actual material flows.
If you drop a leaf into
this flow, and you watch it,
it'll flow along a streamline.
And we can draw those lines.
So what are those?
2xy=1, or the equation y=1/(2x).
That's also a hyperbola, right?
That's also a hyperbola.
This is a fantastic
picture, in which
we have two sets of hyperbolas.
We're second degree, that's why
we're getting two hyperbolas.
I'm not going to tackle drawing
-- MATLAB could do it --
drawing the equipotentials and
the streamlines for this guy.
Oh, but I'm willing
to tackle this one.
What are the equipotentials and
the streamlines for the easiest
one in the list, there?
Can I just draw that one?
Because it makes a point very
clear, that we'll see when
we draw these.
Okay, so what's the picture,
the corresponding picture?
Here is the xy-plane again.
What are the equipotentials
for this pair?
And the streamlines.
The equipotentials are x equal
constant, what are those?
Those are lines, vertical lines.
So the equipotentials
are just vertical lines.
Equipotentials, x
equal a constant.
And what are the streamlines?
Horizontal lines.
Streamlines go this way.
And what's the great
point about these?
These are the streamlines,
s equal constant.
And of course, what
do you notice here?
They're perpendicular.
The streamlines
are perpendicular
to the equipotentials.
And why?
It's because -- you
remember we talked about,
what does the gradient mean?
Which way does the
gradient point?
It points perpendicular
to these equipotentials.
And in this case, all these
equipotentials are parallel,
and the perpendicular
lines are the streamlines,
and they're all parallel.
Now over here, we haven't
got straight lines.
but we still have
the beautiful figure.
Now I'm ready to tackle it.
I'll draw these curves.
They're hyperbolas, like y=1/2x.
If I just make that y=1/2x.
That's a line that
comes down this way.
Let me try to draw it.
I'll use dashed lines.
Of course, as x gets
bigger, y gets smaller.
But y never makes it to
zero, because if y was zero,
no x would work.
But if I change that one to to
a four, I've got a bigger --
this is coming out here.
If I change that to
something very small,
I'll get one that's coming --
Do you see how
the picture works?
These are all right angles.
That's the great thing.
Right angles.
90 degree angles.
Between the streamlines
and the equipotentials.
You may have seen
this before, and now
I just want to ask you why.
Why are those 90 degrees?
We kind of see it physically,
that the gradient --
the flow is in the
gradient direction.
And we know that
gradients are always
perpendicular to
equipotential lines.
The gradient of any function
is perpendicular to the level
curves.
That's all we're seeing here.
But we're seeing these two
fantastic families of curves.
Equipotentials perpendicular
to the streamline.
And the reason
they're perpendicular
is Cauchy-Riemann.
Cauchy-Riemann is telling
us they're perpendicular.
Because the gradient
-- yeah, you see that
they're perpendicular, and this
may be overkill to try to give
a proof.
The gradient of u --
what I want to say is,
the gradient of u is a 90 degree
rotation of the gradient of s.
Let me put it that way.
The gradient of s --
the gradient of u,
rotate 90 degrees, rotate
gradient of u by 90 degrees,
pi/2, and you get grad s.
That's what these equations say.
That if I take the gradient of u
-- yeah, let me try to do that.
So I take the gradient of u.
That's [du/dx, du/dy].
So if I have a vector
in 2-D, [du/dx, du/dy].
And I want to rotate a
vector by 90 degrees.
What's the result?
Suppose I have a vector [a, b],
and I'm looking to rotate it.
What's the vector
that goes that way?
If that vector is [a, b],
that vector should be what?
You may not have done this,
but it's worth just noticing,
and you won't forget it.
It's got to have a zero
dot product, right?
So I'm looking for
a vector, here.
This went out a and up b.
I'm looking for a
vector there that's
perpendicular to this vector.
So what should it do?
What am I going to put there?
A b.
And what am I going
to put -- oh no.
It went backwards, sorry.
When I put there, I should
have put -- minus b.
And what goes there? a.
Yeah.
That's the perpendicular one.
Right?
That's the 90 degree rotation.
And that's what Cauchy-Riemann
is doing for us.
I take the gradient,
I take this vector.
Now I rotate by 90 degrees,
means I reverse these,
reverse the sign, and
I've got the gradient
of S. Or minus
the gradient of S.
I won't say whether
the rotation is plus 90
degrees or minus 90 degrees.
This can remain an exercise
to see it slowly and clearly.
I'm happy if you see it
in the picture there.
And of course, you saw
it in this picture, here.
So this is a moment, then,
to take a little pause.
Because we've got ten
minutes for the great event.
We've got the general idea.
The u equal constants
and the s equal constant.
These two families of
perpendicular curves,
one telling us where level
sets for the potential,
the other telling us the
direction of the flow.
The flow goes perpendicular
to the level sets.
It's just wonderful.
And now I would like to get the
pattern that's going on here
and complete that list.
OK, well that pattern,
like, comes out of the blue,
I have to admit.
You might sort of recognize
it, that something -- here is,
obviously, stuff
to the first power.
Here we've squared
something to get here.
Here we've cubed something.
You sort of recognize
these numbers, 1 3 3 1,
or one, minus three, whatever.
We're taking powers
of something.
And that something is what
comes out of the blue.
It's this quantity, x+iy.
Complex variables.
Everything here was
real until this moment.
And then I'm saying
that the complex number
i, the imaginary number i,
the square root of minus one.
Which of course, it's
not a real number,
but it has the property,
whenever we see i squared,
we write minus one.
So then, we know
how to deal with it.
OK.
Sort of.
Anyway, so that complex
number I'll call z.
And here's what I think.
I think that these two
pieces are the real
and the imaginary parts of z.
Now, these two
pieces are the real
and the imaginary
parts of z squared.
These two pieces
will be the real part
and the imaginary
part of z cubed.
And if we check
that, and then we
begin to see, why should these
satisfy Laplace's equation,
we'll have the whole pattern.
It'll just be x+iy,
fourth power, fifth power,
sixth power.
We can make a complete, infinite
list of pairs of solutions
to Laplace's equation.
So let me just check what I
said about the squares first.
How do you do x+iy squared?
Because that's what
I believe we're
seeing in the quadratic list.
So I claim that if I take x+iy
squared, just do it normally,
I get x squared, and I get 2ixy,
and I get i squared y squared.
Right?
I just squared it, following
normal algebra rules.
Now what's the real part?
What's the real part of this
x+iy squared? x squared,
this is real.
And this is real, because
i squared is minus one,
this says minus y
squared, that's our guy.
And the imaginary part is 2xy.
The imaginary part is the
part that multiplies i.
So by some magic -- next time is
the fun of exploring this magic
-- we get solutions
to a real equation.
We get two solutions
to a real equation,
by working with this
complex thing, x+iy,
and taking things like -- now,
if I go to x+iy cubed, well,
let me just say it'll work.
We'll have -- it's like,
if you cube something,
you're going to see 1 3 3 1.
You'll have an x cubed, and a
3x squared iy, and a 3xiy twice,
and a one of the iy cubed.
And then you look to see what
part is real, and you say,
x cubed is real.
And i squared is the minus,
so I have minus 3xy squared.
Golden.
And you look for what
part is imaginary,
and you see the 3x squared
y, and you see the i cubed --
so what's i cubed?
-- is minus i.
So that's an imaginary term,
with the minus we wanted.
So now we've got
the whole thing.
We've got solutions
to Laplace's equation,
coming from all the powers.
This is now the
moment to celebrate.
Because we've got a
giant family of solutions
to Laplace's equation.
We've got the real parts.
So u is the real part
of x+iy to any power.
And s will be the
imaginary part.
And I claim that, just as it
held for n equal one, two,
three, for every n,
these will be solutions
to Laplace's equation.
Not only that, they'll be
connected by Cauchy-Riemann,
so they'll be the potential and
the stream function for a flow.
And we've got lots of them.
And, why don't we get
even more, because we
have a linear equation here.
So what are we allowed to
do, if we have solutions
to a linear
equation, what are we
allowed to do with
those solutions
to get more solutions?
Combine them.
I can take any
combination of these guys.
I can take "or." "And,"
"or," I don't know which,
should I put "or," "and?"
The real part of any
combination of these.
So I could take a combination
of, I can take coefficients
c_k, or c_n, maybe I should
say c_n, (x+iy) to the nth.
So if I take a
combination of solutions,
with coefficient c_n,
I still have solutions.
And what will be the twin
solution, or the stream
function that goes with this u?
So this is another u, this is
virtually a complete family
of u.
Because we have all these
coefficients to choose.
And what will be the s?
So what's the
corresponding s, then?
It's the imaginary part of
-- what? -- the same thing.
We're just taking
that same combination
of the special ones.
So the special
ones were (x+iy)^n.
And the combinations are those.
Yeah.
These are fantastic solutions.
And now, since I'm blessed
with two more minutes,
I get to make them much easier.
Because already when I got
up to x cubed and y cubed,
they're looking messy.
You say, okay, great to
have all these solutions,
but how am I going to use them?
They're getting more and more
complicated as n increases.
But switch to polar coordinates.
Make the same list
in polar coordinates.
So again, I'm just going
to list the same guys
in polar coordinates r, theta.
Then you'll see
the pattern, then
the pattern really jumps out.
So what is x in
polar coordinates?
If I switch from x, y,
rectangular coordinates, to r,
theta, polar coordinates,
x is r*cos(theta).
And y is r*sin(theta).
Well, so far it doesn't look
any easier. x and y look fine.
But let me go to the second one.
So this is now r squared
cos squared theta, right?
Minus, this is r squared
sine squared theta.
Trigonometry comes in.
I have r squared
cos squared theta,
minus r squared sine squared
theta, I want to simplify that.
So it's got an r
squared, and it's got
a cos squared theta
minus sine squared theta.
Anybody remember
that? cos(2theta)!
And this one.
Well, what do you
think is coming?
What do you think
is coming here?
I have 2r*cos(theta)
times r*sin(theta).
I have two, I've got
an r squared, again,
times 2cos(theta)*sin(theta).
So what's
2cos(theta)*sin(theta)?
sin(2theta).
You get it. sin(2theta).
And you know what's
coming next, right?
You know that now, the whole
family in polar coordinates --
what's the nth power?
We can now write down
the nth one in this list.
It is r^n -- for the nth
pair, r^n times cos(n*theta),
and r^n sin(n*theta).
So those are the
twins, the u and the s
that we get if we use
polar coordinates.
So that's just terrific.
Now we have a whole
lot of solutions
to Laplace's equation.
And we have, don't forget,
all combinations of them.
And we're really ready to go.
So Friday we'll be solving
Laplace's equation in the cases
that we can do it, by
pencil and paper, by chalk.
And then, after that, comes
solving Laplace's equation
by finite differences
and finite elements.